[Music]
we're really excited to come towards its
back with dimensions and its really big
honor for us but it's going to be one of
the first title towns yeah that's a huge
thing for us Lucy game geometry wars is
part of our DNA part of our heritage so
we're really excited to work with
someone's exciting and he was Ciera and
to show what we can work with since the
last version of geometry wars there's
been a new generation of change machines
coming out and we really want to see
we're using that power we want to see
where we could take the gameplay make it
push it more forward and help some new
surprises we've got these new
three-dimensional battle grids
we've got competitive multiplayer game
modes the first time we've got a brand
new cooperative multiplayer mode and
we've also brought back sort of key
features like the drones and some really
exciting powers one of the really
exciting new things dimensions is the
gameplays just on on a plane now
three-dimensional grid we look to the
game we want to make sure the grid
meaning warps changes even within on
levels and it just creates this new
dynamic battlefield you now can or will
always take the enemies I think of the
other side of the shape you've got to
think about how to move the shape or the
best angles of attack cars with it
really has a huge tactical layers of the
game that maybe wasn't in the previous
versions intelligence well they're
really exciting things we've now put
time into boss battle and it's always
being asked into those rather than just
having hundreds and of these smaller
shapes you know but these kind of big
badass levels to play against but
everybody adds an extra tactical depth
our variation to the play they work very
much almost at their own special levels
there's a lot of puzzles and sort of
using tricks to kill the boss where
different strategies different gameplay
tactics are really important as you play
again to conquer the box multiplayer is
going to be awesome just something
people have asked for for years never in
the previous versions of Jhansi Wars
it's great to get in there as a huge
level of competitiveness between players
it's not just about leaderboards anymore
now you can go head-to-head so how it
works very much it's all that a long
takedown you outsmart your opponent or
your team could be admin against another
team and you could run different
strategies to overall sort of conquer
the grid players don't have loads of
different things that's like to take
into the battle with them
different attack drones different
superpowers they can take you with them
you can level them up tailor them with
their own special powers to drop them
off almost like a gun in place and come
on it taking out certain enemies and
again in that level of choice for the
player is unprecedented in French and
also it gives that level of versatility
and variety of a little secretly it's
great to be back with Microsoft on Xbox
360 and Xbox one
what's great is and we're also on
PlayStation 3 and PlayStation 4 as well
as on PC if you've a fan of the previous
games you've got to play this game just
take it so many of the elements we've
pushed in for return to 11 the action is
more intense it takes all of these
things which moves it much more forward
once you've experienced the intense
action I'm sure